Windows includes a built-in firewall
they refer to as the Windows Defender
Firewall. This firewall is always
enabled and ideally you would always
have this configured and running on your
Windows system, but there may be times
when you want to do some troubleshooting
and perhaps temporarily disable the
firewall while you run those
troubleshooting steps. You can either
start the Windows Defender Firewall
frontend from the control panel or
launch it from the search option inside
of Windows. From here, you'll see
different networks that have been
configured. For example, you can have
one set of security policies if you're
connected to a private network and a
completely different set of security
policies if you're connected to a public
network. Just remember that you'll need
elevated rights if you want to choose
the option to turn off the Windows
Defender firewall. There are some very
broad settings you can configure inside
of Windows Defender for each one of
these different categories of network.
For example, if you're on a private
network or a public network, you can
choose individual settings for each of
those network connections. Broadly
speaking, you can turn on Windows
firewall. If the firewall is turned on,
you can choose to block all incoming
connections, including those that you
may have explicitly allowed. This should
be turned on if you're concerned about
anybody trying to connect to your
system. And you can choose to have
Windows Defender notify you if it blocks
a new app. But you might need more
granularity than that when it comes to
setting firewall rules. For example, you
might have a specific application that
is running on your computer and you'd
like to allow it to receive incoming
connections. Or if you don't want to
specify a particular executable, you can
simply use a port number that that
application uses. Windows Defender also
includes a large list of predefined
applications that you can then set to
enable or disable depending on where you
may be connected. And if none of these
apply, you may want to build your own
exception using the tools available
inside of Windows Defender
Firewall. From our control panel, we
know that Windows Defender Firewall is
right here at the bottom. We'll select
that and it will bring up the settings
for Windows Defender Firewall. This one
has settings for our domain networks,
our private networks, and our guest or
public networks. You can see right now
that Windows Defender is on. It blocks
all connections that are not on the
list. It tells me what my current
private network happens to be. And this
is set to not notify me if it blocks a
new app. I would like to turn on the
power user mode of Windows firewall. And
these advanced settings are available by
clicking this option in the lefth hand
menu. This will bring up a separate
window that is called the Windows
Defender Firewall with advanced
security. This allows you as the
administrator access to modify every
possible configuration that's available
inside of Windows Defender. Let's have a
look at the inbound rules. You can see
there's a large number of inbound rules
already set. There are outbound rules
also available in Defender Firewall.
There are connection security rules that
you can configure and there's monitoring
tools included as well. Let's create a
new inbound rule inside of Windows
Defender Firewall. We'll choose that
option and we'll right mouse click on
the words inbound rule and we'll choose
the option for a new rule. This brings
up a dialogue box that allows me to set
a new rule type and I can create one
based on an application or program. I
can create a rule that includes a TCP or
a UDP port. I could choose any of the
predefined rules that are inside of
Windows Defender or I can create a
custom rule. Quickly, let's look at the
predefined rules. You can see there are
a large number of rules that are already
built into Windows Firewall. But let's
create our own rule by choosing the
custom option and clicking next. The
first option is for program where we can
specify a certain application that will
apply for this rule or we can choose
that all applications apply to this
rule. Let's keep that one in place and
click next. Now we can select a protocol
and a port number. Let's say in our
scenario that we want to prevent anyone
from connecting to a web server that's
running on our computer using port 80,
which is the non- enrypted form of web
communication. To be able to do that,
we'll need to set a rule that blocks all
incoming traffic that is inbound on TCP
port 80. And so from the protocols and
ports window, we're going to specify
that this is a TCP port. We're then
going to choose the local port that will
be used. In this case, it is a specific
port and not all ports. And we're going
to specify port 80. The remote port or
the port that is coming from the remote
device can be any port number for this
rule. So, we'll choose those options and
click next. It then says what local IP
address does this rule apply to. This
could be any IP address on this local
device or from a remote IP address or we
can specify an individual IP address
that we would like to use for this rule.
In this case, we'll keep both of these
as any IP address and we'll click next.
Now we have the disposition of what we
would like to do with this traffic if it
matches this rule. We can allow this
connection, allow it if it's secure, or
block the connection. Since we want to
block everything using TCP port 80, we
will choose to block the connection and
click next. Windows now wants us to
define what network is going to apply
this particular rule. Will this be the
domain network, a private network or a
public network. In this case, it will be
any of those connections. So, we'll
leave the default check marks in place
and click next. Now, we have to give
this rule a name. We'll say block
unencrypted web traffic and we'll click
finish. And now we've created a brand
new rule that blocks any unencrypted web
traffic that is inbound to our computer
using TCP port 80.